in our morning rounds a new study
reveals a longer life might be an
unexpected benefit of cataract surgery
cataract removal is the most frequently
performed operation in the u.s. around 4
million Americans had the surgery last
year and now a large study of women
links the eye procedure to a 60% lower
risk of dying from all causes Wow dr.
Christopher Starr is an ophthalmologist
at Weill Cornell Medical Center and is
joining us with more I didn't know that
it was the number one procedure done in
this country yeah it's very common
almost everybody if you live long enough
you get cataract so there and with the
baby boomers aging lots of people need
cataract surgery so as she said for 4
million people in the US alone each year
have cataract surgery have a surgery but
24 million have them yes a lot of people
have cataracts who don't necessarily
need cataract surgery
cataracts don't always require surgery
you can have a mild cataract and still
function well and therefore you can wait
on the surgery what are cataracts yeah
so what is a cataract so we're born we
have nice clear translucent lenses as we
get older they get yellow where they get
more opaque and less translucent and
therefore the vision gets blurred and
that's what a cataract is think of a
dirty lens on your eye glasses or
contact lenses or a dirty windshield or
dirty lens on a camera same idea when it
gets cloudy the vision decreases the
data is really interesting because one
study looked at over 70,000 older women
with cataracts and many of those who
have the surgery lived longer what's the
connection yeah isn't that amazing and
the connection is it's not so much that
cataract surgery does anything to a
heart or in the brain or the
cardiovascular system but what it does
do is it improves quality of life and by
improving quality of life by improving
vision you also can improve quantity of
life you're living longer and the theory
is that because the vision has improved
you're more agile you're gonna trip and
fall less you might be more physically
active might exercise more you can get
to the doctor more often you can take
your medications and see what you're
taking and more motivation really to
live new view on life new lease on life
kind of UI are more women prone to
having cataracts that's a good question
we think it's postmenopausal Eve
decrease in estrogen probably leads to
an increased risk of cataract and there
is some data that estrogen therapy after
menopause can actually decrease the risk
of cataract Wow so it's that's not yet
hormonal and it is genetic - and there
is a genetic if you have both parents
cataracts at early ages you're probably
more likely to get a cataract as well
but everybody gets cataracts if you've
had LASIK surgery yes that prevent
cataracts it does not it does not sorry
normally that's a little bit of
complexity to the actual cataract
surgery when you know 50 years from now
when you actually need to have cataracts
thank goodness they're great doctors
like you out there dr. christow started
you so much